yeah  you gotta reckon income  we're gonna end this  you will never have my permission where  is she  no come on  we have to go  you need to help my daughter  load up let's get to it  do you think anyone's following us  we're okay it's Mark over the sheriff  we'll make it right in the end  my men and I are here to bring that boy  in  alive  so if you're here on some sort of  Vendetta slightly complicate things  yeah I will find him and you're welcome  to every piece of him when I'm done  you hear me  I was in control here  I love you your horses carry this sent  to death as you wander around this  desert with a bunch of children  lawmen enforcing your loss on foreign  land  I am tired of it  is not the way  peace doesn't follow death does it  [Music]